I have a cord you're good good I promise
I promise you I feeling I'm not good
isn't your kind of intimidating because
I could feel like yours everyone told me
I'm intimidating and aggressive you got
this high aggressive energy energy work
today so I should be chill you know
wanted let me scare every guy away
you're so scary and I'm like well then
the canyons their fault come on I'm not
forty-five be like okay I'm gonna tone
it down
[Laughter]
Hey ladies and gentlemen my name is Greg
Alva well I didn't if you're going to
sneak not Arianna bata is Arianna
bothering gotta channel didn't carry job
Arianna badassery on Instagram and
Twitter and she's on YouTube as Arianna
bussers yeah hey Arianna one of my
favorite channels how's that going so
one of my favorite naps away this is
good this is a good sweat this is the
boob sweat what's your question
one in five minutes Arianna there's this
channel called raka raka raka raka does
these sketches that often go very
violent they're from Island sometimes
they go violent sometimes you just go
weird okay doesn't matter you know which
one this one does I have no clue it's
called we got a mansion okay let me just
look cute first okay ready
[Laughter]
hello Danny
we got the [ __ ] house I'm going
to show you how I get [ __ ] so [ __ ]
idiot I didn't know sort of is my comic
collection a [ __ ] a [ __ ] - so I only
got kicked out of this house so now is
moving along tomorrow why do you keep
down your house from tells bitter old
man isn't it true does your mother call
the cops and kick you earlier how
[Music]
[Music]
here we go to Mexico Danny he's making
scrub me how to put down on Twitter are
you thank you every now and again it
happens pretty well there no for like
the strength up when they do tension and
now
long for their discretion bench what is
it Kimberly strobe I'm not Eliza go play
I button see that YouTube you well 100k
to show you hit I'm very curious gonna
come here to get a view fancy looking
sorry bed you don't know I wish his
bumper yeah sorry there's a white mama
[Laughter]
I'll get you ready quality yes amazing
Wow [ __ ] now see they're really fine
you want to be in a house you'll be the
funeral editing station this is the
guest room get wasted me and they're
gonna do throw it in the laundry out the
[ __ ] way man this is the sauna and it
seems upset small for man so happy about
a two bedroom number one Walker I'm
talking about another bathtub ah [ __ ]
what was it out Richie [ __ ] drop us
in the [ __ ] shop and [ __ ] like
watchin fuckabish era fuzzy
I've national
[Music]
Jonah's girl she doesn't know the
officer did it safely
are you ready for the best room in the
house you don't even break your fall
bride nanny don't jump in the balcony to
me oh thanks I yeah it's great all right
look LeAnn what's the bare basics you
Boris be like disgusting place and these
giris sauces and LeAnn hates Jaden
because Jade always breaks oh [ __ ]
accidentally what we're going to do is
alia Jaden to smash these plates
internally and watch her she reacts in
traditional camera
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
your voice Ritchie the voice up was a
review of my son pick another Sheldon
your room yet
do you like it government I love you bye
Richie wish to get upset holy book shall
prosper my finger and again jay-z and
oppressor IDs looking out rated so
expensive my cultural talking [ __ ] I
mean I miss a lot with mattress look up
many [ __ ] stains on the stage take
that piss off all spit same what savings
how do you know [ __ ] Danny dr. Serizawa
reason and you feed my lord
hell no dozen must many you're the older
brother
hey there were this big room all
I wanted to masters they wanna be one of
them maybe I wrote the people and how
ultimately should decide this the
old-fashioned way just spot until you
microwave percent right here
we don't own people of all went out when
I start where my awesome but it was it
was the chest little the shop right do
it
Jimmy rapper who Johnny boy Johnny just
should arrive enjoy absolutely some I
think I'll be adjusted you're the only
pack now let it sells in my Swiss Army
here it a little kitchen with everyone
that comes to school
[Music]
[Laughter]
there's many so much money there's a lot
of things like that shifting silk
operability like this a lot yeah to me
it's beautiful parity here does our
module be one of the best exactly what I
do upset
[Music]
top know what try it my Christmas
strength God would this is really sad
ourselves the fact that JD's never going
to see us together not beyond over
anymore
yeah you're upset we leaving game see
every weekend stop yeah we're going to
miss you too but we're never going to
see you again aah oh my I'm gonna be
see-through body we'd live next chain
for a long time three years a real party
oh you again activist tell her to come
over time you're hanging out now we're
going to be there anymore you'll live
lift and the south goddesses we're not
going to miss you at all yeah see you
later guys so we have three for your
people dailies won't like shall we hit a
hundred fifty thousand lights so you
need to smash that like button
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] army and lowdown insomnia slow
my name is blue with no high libido
pounding maneuver for our missus show
that's why I love me over this is nuts I
thought it was going to turn to a sketch
the whole time why I knew at a certain
point it sure wasn't Wow good for you
you have amazing observation skills that
I don't possess that's insane holy crap
up these guys going I've been following
these guys for a few years now really
yeah like these awesome hilarious crazy
sketches I'd love to see one and now
they're moving into a mansion or a crap
they seem like the kind of guys you a
date what kind of guy do you think I
would date like crazy like frat boy
personality while anyone that's how I
feel like I feel like these are the kind
of guys you would like hang out with or
be they would want to me I was like a
loud girl why not they're so freaking
loud yeah it's not that all I got no a
girlfriends that our life is very
beautiful and quiet know we could
probably go on their Instagram can I
show you telling me you wouldn't want to
hang out with these guys no I'm just a
housing they want to have me never gonna
have like a fun loud guy
why because I think it's like an energy
balance I feel like the way you were
like laughing at others or dumb jokes
seem like these are the kind of guys
you'd be very drawn to in real life as
friends maybe that's it they would want
to do I'm telling you it just doesn't
work like that
I don't think that like loud and crazy
guys want like a loud and crazy girl or
same-sex you know whenever I'm including
everyone well even though this is your
first Rock of raqqa video wasn't a
sketch what you think of it they were
cute and fun and funny I like them and
I'm good energy inside I like that they
have like a lady friend yeah one of my
dreams is to be in Iraq Iraq
- because their sketches tend to be like
they tend to go down this path or it
seems like a normal day that's why I
thought I was gonna turn to this castle
yeah you should just go to there
yeah just fly across the country and ask
you might be in one of their videos did
they put you in if you flew they're
probably here look Greg go I've actually
a column just a pokémon's if it when I
was figure I go feel like I'd be
intimidated hang out with them really
like I could go really quiet you do that
I do that a lot louder on camera and
you're very high are you kidding you're
no quiet in person yeah person I'm a
listener yeah it's true Greg will be
like so even therapy very quiet yes I'm
catching up yeah I'm a listener but I
don't know if I'm not usually more fun
and then I get here I'm like just try to
focus on this if you get all this and
we're not in front of the camera that's
right adjust your energy my boobs are
too bright yeah I guess what I just care
so much about looking there's so much
about the way you look does that worry
about it don't worry about it but your
hands down your pants act like Al Bundy
who gives a [ __ ]
just be you that's all I want for you
I'm always me even if I haven't even if
you're sorry no self conscious so you
know that's the most like transparent me
I suppose so accept that
alright fine when you talk about well
yeah we're doing terrible at staying on
topic here I would love to have a
mansion like that one day that'd be
crazy if one day I could build it myself
so should be fun with with your friends
or to live with it by myself
be my quiet self in my mansion yeah a
woman
I need bro live alone that is good it's
true I mean who are you talking to all
day I'm with people all the time yeah me
too I like not I like going and being
alone I gosh would you live in a mansion
like by yourself in something no cuz
their IDs please check for murderers in
all the rooms my right you know I want
to team to the average American
expand look bigger so if you got a
mansion who would you live with it would
be your choices like in a friend why
should we're getting to good rollers for
that know or not I don't want to just I
say I don't even want to live with any
of my friends
Wow really you wouldn't live with any of
your friends no I love all my friends
and I want to keep living them
I feel like one little pebble never
lived with someone romantically and my
one of my best friends who I'm still
very close friends with but I feel like
it takes out the fun of everything I
believe it's more fun to invite friends
over and then they leave I thought I
could live with John Yeley then they're
like weirdly connected at the balls or
something yeah codependent is one
awesome insane we're not codependent
well you're like don't say that John
teller over Taco Time Hey Joe Cocker
attend did not go to pinon I was good
thanks John tt and I love you too would
you the three songs another guy if it is
John yeah no I wouldn't want to see
John's penis have you seen it I'm sure
you've seen a nobody seen mine too many
times by it
Matt no if I had a mansion like this I
would totally live in a few people I
don't want to be alone or like just like
you only want like roommates so I hope
eventually I'll have like a significant
other you would have a family do you
want to have family with it yeah don't
you you know I hate that we're talking
about this oh never mind it would just
be a flat mansion look at image you're
trying to maintain herself yeah I'm 20
years old
intimacy for suckers no subscriber in
horrid shakes wrapping this up why would
that notification bell sorry on a bad
tree on Instagram and Twitter where
she's all about family values and
patience go check her out there on
YouTube where it's all about meditation
serenity yeah yo
and how to find your inner joy and peace
and not be reliant on people providing
validation for you
that is what Arianna is all about I got
your back there I'm not even like 15
years now I know who you really are
I'm sorry that when you come over to
catch up I like to let you talk and I go